bonjour à tous bonjour à toi qui n'a aps
l'école et bienvenue dans la maison
lumière la maison l'unil émission qui
donne un coup de pouce aux élèves
pendant le confinement jamais
l'éducation n'a eu autant de place à la
télévision avant ça elle en avait même
perdu au fil du temps si on pouvait la
prendre les choses avec la devise 1953
les tout débuts
la télévision scolaire est lancé c'est
le moyen qu'a trouvé le gouvernement
pour moderniser l'éducation avec des
leçons diffusé à la télé c'est une
innovation considérable qui vient
s'ajouter aux cours par radio inauguré
l'an dernier dans les années soixante
quatre heures de programmes scolaires
sont diffusés chaque semaine
à l'époque peu de français sont équipés
d'une télé ces cours filmés sont vus en
classe avec le professeur la télévision
rapporte quelques jours de trêve à
l'abbé très intéressant d'un certain
matière d'enseignement
par exemple en histoire c'est un fait en
géographe et de paiement sont
remarquables à partir des années 80 qui
le ministère de l'éducation tente de
repenser ses émissions des projets sont
avancés puis abandonnée pendant ce temps
les programmes scolaires faire de la
place à l'antenne ce n'est qu'en 1994
qu'une nouvelle offre éducative voit le
jour avec le lancement d'une nouvelle
chaîne la cinquième c'est pour ça
qu'elle a été
pour aider à la diffusion du savoir mais
aussi une chaîne où on trouve autre
chose que ce qu'on trouve sur les autres
on tienne davantage compte des
aspirations notamment de la jeunesse
il ne s'agit plus de programmes purement
scolaire mais éducatif
ils ne sont plus destinés à être vus en
classe mais à la maison par les enfants
comme ce cours d'anglais scénarisé en
1996 niveau ce1 maison 2001 quand la
cinquième de via france 5 une refonte
des programmes jeunesse laisse moins de
place à l'éducation au bénéfice de
dessins animés depuis le relais a été
pris par les outils numériques
néanmoins sur france 5 il a été envisagé
de diffuser des cours en cas de
fermeture de toutes les écoles du pays
la première fois que le scénario a été
envisagée c'était en 2006 à cause de
l'épidémie de grippe aviaire
alors maintenant attendez vous placez le
vendredi sur la prise trois mois de
cours prêts à être diffusés finalement
resté dans les placards ils ont failli
en sortir en 2009 à cause de la grippe a
mais il n'y a pas eu de fermeture
générale des écoles seuls quelques
classes ont fermé et pour elle les cours
ont continué par internet
[Musique]